It is Thursday, which means we have the latest
unemployment report from the previous week.
The numbers are staggering.
Once again, an additional 4.4 million new
people filed for unemployment benefits last
week.
These are what we call initial claims when
you first filed for benefits.
Remember that we get the numbers on Thursday
from the previous week.
So let's look at the total numbers since the
start of the Corona virus pandemic.
Remember that before the pandemic, the most
jobless claims we had had in one week was
in 1982, I believe, and it was somewhere between
six and eight hundred thousand.
I don't remember the numbers exactly, but
compare them to the numbers from the last
five weeks.
The week ending March 21, 3.3 million new
jobless claims week ending March 28.
6.8 million.
April 4th. 6.6 million.
April eleven.
Another 5.2 million.
And then the week ending April 18, 4.4 million.
So this is now a total of twenty six point
four million people who have filed for unemployment
since the start of the corona virus pandemic.
We believed that the labor force was about
158 million right before this started.
So what this means is that nearly 17 percent
of the country has lost their jobs in the
last five weeks.
So a few different things.
First of all, the scope and magnitude of this,
these are job loss numbers that would have
been inconceivable four months ago or four
months ago.
Someone said how would the economy react to
17 percent of the country losing their jobs?
It's cartoonish.
These are cartoonishly huge numbers.
No one alive today lived through anything
like this in their working lives.
OK.
We have now lost more jobs in the last five
weeks than the total number of jobs created
since the Great Recession.
OK, so let me clarify those numbers.
During the 2008 recession, we lost 8.7 million
jobs since we started recovering from that
recession.
Twenty two point four million jobs were created
total since 2009.
OK, we now have lost more than 26 million
in the last five weeks.
The entire jobs recovery from the recession,
including the jobs created under Barack Obama
and the roughly 6 million that were created
under Donald Trump up until this started.
All of those jobs are gone.
So that's number one.
The magnitude of it.
Number two, every one of us that has a job
should be very grateful because the situation
is truly horrifying, that that's just an interjection.
Even people who have lost jobs and want to
go on unemployment insurance are having trouble.
So it's not as simple as well.
You lose your job, the government's going
to bail you out.
There are states that may soon run out of
unemployment money.
Many people just aren't hearing back for weeks.
Many people filed or attempted to file weeks
ago.
They haven't gotten a dollar yet because the
systems are so overwhelmed, truly dystopian.
Now, in terms of the outlook, even if new
claims slow down and they probably will.
Right.
So we may go down to only 3.8 million new
claims next week and maybe 3.4 the fault,
right?
You could have a declining growth rate.
The total number of people on unemployment
could continue climbing in total over the
next few months.
Depending on the spread of the pandemic.
We could have 30 million.
We could have 35 million.
I spoke to one economist who thinks by July,
depending on how things go, we could have
40 million people on unemployment benefits.
Can the states even afford that?
It's not clear.
Now you have a contingent from the right that
says just open it up and it will all get resolved
because the economy will restart.
Doesn't seem to be the case because unless
and until you deal with the pandemic, when
you you can open a restaurant, you can open
a barbershop, you can open a nail salon.
Doesn't mean that people are going to go.
It's not going to fix this.
If here in Massachusetts right now, salons
and barber shops opened up, I'm not going
to get a haircut.
Nobody I've spoken to is going to get a haircut.
What good is taking someone off of unemployment
benefits so that they can stand in a barbershop,
clippers and scissors in hand with no customers
coming in?
So with history as our guide, we know that
the one way to deal with this is to deal with
the virus itself as quickly as possible.
Now there's new research, there's new studies
that are suggesting that lockdown down or
not, the curve is roughly similar in in growth
rate, not in absolute numbers.
And that is something we should be thinking
about.
I'm going to be studying that tomorrow, over
the weekend.
And I'll I'll come to you with information
about that on Monday.
But opening business is just so people can
stand there without customers is not a path.
It's not a strategy.
It's not really anything.
States can't really open economies.
People can open economies.
And despite the Astroturf protests, which
we'll talk about later today, most people
right now aren't willing to go and pretend
everything is normal, even if a bunch of businesses
start opening up.
Very important
to understand that.